hello welcome good evening everyone it
is so lovely to be at an actual physical
event and we will be bringing together
you the audience in the room and the
audience online and um it is lovely to
be here our intelligence Square debate
tonight is sanctions against Russia
won't work uh you'll be hearing some
impassioned intelligent uh arguments on
both sides and you are going to be part
of this event and this debate
so
we all know what we're thinking about
nine months after Russia's invasion of
Ukraine the enormity of the crime is
still unfolding the U.S state state
department special Ambassador this week
has called this a new Nuremberg moment
she's described systemic war crimes in
every region where Russian forces have
been deployed deliberate indiscriminate
disproportionate attacks against
civilians
as we consider the appropriate and
effective response do we think that
sanctions should be key before we begin
our debate I'm going to get a sense from
you the audience of where your opinions
lie so we're going to ask you for a
pre-vote you may have done this already
but if not I'm going to ask you to use
the QR code use your phones to scan the
code or you got the um
the link as well I think in emails
before the event
and you have three options you can vote
for the motion against the motion or of
course you can be unsure you can be
undecided and if you're watching on the
live stream you just find that voting
Link in our chat
and we'll keep you on tender hooks for a
little while we'll announce the results
of the pre-vote after our opening
speeches then you know uh what there is
to play for uh and and where the
audience sentiment is right now so we're
going to start with our opening speeches
and I'm going to introduce our speakers
one by one for you to hear what they
have to say our first speaker in favor
of the motion that sanctions against
Russia won't work is Simon Jenkins Simon
I'm going to invite you to go up to the
podium you'll know Simon journalist
author he writes twice weekly for the
guardian he's worked on The Economist
and the Sunday Times he has edited the
evening standard and the times Simon's
many books include works on London's
architecture the Press British politics
his best sellers include I'm going to
ask you to walk up to the podium uh
England's thousand best churches and
thousand best houses a study of saturism
short histories of London England and
Europe and tonight Simon like the other
speakers here has 10 minutes to speak to
the motion that sanctions against Russia
won't work
thank you very much indeed
thank you
and welcome once again to live
um I uh I want to emphasize one thing
from the very beginning of this debate
there have been many debates on Ukraine
and uh we all I think know now what we
think about it uh the war
um we on this side of the of the motion
are not discussing whether Russia was
right or wrong to invade Ukraine Uh
Russian Russian invasion of Ukraine was
an appalling aggression
um I believe that it was wrong I believe
Ukraine was right in resisting it as it
is done I believe that NATO was right in
coming to Ukraine's Aid it was right to
give it military assistance it was also
right to be careful that that assistance
only went to Ukraine it did not stray
into Russia everything about the
military side of this war has in my view
been acted correctly from the West's
point of view so we're not discussing
the Rights and Wrongs of the war we're
discussing one a very specific thing uh
that is economic sanctions a quite
separate question from the war in my
view at least now sanctions ever since
the the second world war have been in
many ways the favorite weapon of more
liberal uh Western regimes
when they've been concerned to intervene
in the evils of the world wherever they
may be they have been on the whole uh
ineffective in that they haven't
achieved their goal and indeed Nicholas
Muller who's written one of the very few
books on sanctions it's an
extraordinarily neglected subject
he studied about 35 sanctions most of
them stood in place and he pointed out
that almost never did they achieve their
goal what they did was they were hurtful
so we're not arguing that sanctions
Don't Hurt You couldn't possibly argue
that and you looked at the history of
sanctions places like Iraq where the
most vicious sanctions were imposed
thousands of people probably died
through being denied medicines under
sanctions
um the UN has calculated that about a
third of the poor in the world are
operating or living under the cloud of
economic sanctions imposed by the West
they isolate regimes they entrenched
regimes they repress dissent they
bolster autocratic regimes in their
autocracy they are crippling of these
regimes but they don't seem to undermine
them and I think it's this inability to
undermine power that lies at the heart
of the ineffectiveness of sanctions
ineffective in not achieving their
political goal because they are a
political weapon
um never have sanctions directly
undermined the victim power that they
were intended to do it is quite
extraordinary Mulder in his book
assesses the effectiveness of sanctions
political Effectiveness or sanctions and
reaches the conclusion that on the whole
they may have 20 percent Effectiveness
in achieving any political goal at all
in his book actually describes the
history of sanctions as the history of
disappointments simple as that uh and
then when you look at the countries that
were set I have been sanctioned against
uh Cuba North Korea Iran Iraq
Afghanistan Syria Myanmar Venezuela all
these countries have a curious solidity
about them some of them were
subsequently attacked militarily but the
sanctions never achieved their goal of
toppling the regime I think probably if
I was running an autocracy I'd plead
with the Americans sanction me
sanctioned me I I think probably that's
the surest way of achieving both
internal stability for my regime and
actually
um
security from being attacked outside
um it is it is a it's the most bizarre
phenomenon that the most popular weapon
deployed by the West aggressively
against other countries should also be
the most ineffective it is a bizarre
thesis but it is the spaces on which
we're proposing this motion now um
one of the reasons for this I think is
that people misjudge the nature of
economic power and they think that and
largely these are people in the West in
capitalist countries they think that
money is part
curiously autocratic regimes but also
all regimes when they're in a state of
bellicosity when they're belligerent
um discard considerations of cost they
don't worry about the money it was very
noticeable even during the Faulkner's
War the British government
prevented Jeffrey Howe the chancellor of
the exchecker from ever attending a war
cabinet they didn't want him to come up
and say we can't afford it money was not
to be the issue when war is being fought
and this is so clearly the case I think
in in the in in the case of of Putin at
the moment
most of the countries that have
sanctions attached to them are small
poor states doesn't mean the sanctions
actions are effective it just means they
all have to be poor small states Russia
is probably the biggest and most
powerful state to have concerted
economic sanctions inflicted on it and
they have had the most extraordinary and
devastating sanctions inflicted on them
their problems one is that sanctions
always leak in the case of Russia
sanctions of elite to Iran and China
helping it in in the one as you respect
in which they needed help particularly
with a small equipment for their weapons
but the real problem is that Russia also
has power to hit back
now I'm told that nobody ever in the
course of the planning of British
assistance to Ukraine ever discussed
what might be the consequence of
sanctions against Russia for Britain
they just didn't think of it because
sanctions are so natural the response to
any uh conflict that they simply don't
worry about what might be the effect or
the ineffectiveness of them
as it has been as well no
um Russia does have the power to hurt
the worst with gas and oil sanctions and
with other raw materials and it did not
propose to do that at the beginning of
this war but it did react to the
Declaration of economic sanctions
against it in other words this separate
War the war the economic war with Russia
is quite separate from the war about
Ukraine it is actually a war declared by
the West collectively against Russia
although it was not prepared to declare
war against Russia militarily as a
result of which Russia could fight back
more effectively I think and it's been
able to fight back militarily in Ukraine
um indeed I think and I'm pretty sure no
one ever predicted the degree of
instability that Russian reaction to
sanctions has inflicted on the west I'm
almost tempted to say that if I was
trying to propose a motion the sanctions
against the West might work
um uh because of the of the effect that
these sanctions have had on the west I
might be much more difficult much more
difficulty arguing the case
um sanctions on the west have been
extraordinarily effective because
look at Donald Trump's Fallen Boris
Johnson's Fallen this trust has fallen
um the the the the German and French and
Italian governments have been
destabilized
um the effect of the sanctions on Russia
in response to them has really been
devastating uh probably the cost of the
sanctions to the West has been much
greater than the cost of supporting
Ukraine militarily
so you do have a situation in which you
have to say what on Earth was the point
of this exercise the sanctions aren't
effective they aren't uh they aren't um
hurting Russia they're hurting Russia
but they aren't affecting Russian
decisions over the war petition is
peculiarly resistant to any um
thing the West does in in in in in the
way in which he conducts this war
um when in 2004 the sanctions were first
imposed
um uh the sanctions were described as
deterring him from going any further in
Ukraine they were conspicuously
unsuccessful in that respect
um and I have to say that that um that
in the in the case of the sanctions
which were imposed on him the only
response that the West could do when
criticized for those sanctions was to
say well we couldn't think of anything
else to do and anyway maybe we didn't
impose them severely enough well we've
now imposed them even more severely
indeed the most severe sanctions ever in
history and they're still not worked in
deterring Putin from the most horrific
crimes in the Crimea in in Ukraine
now all like all I can do in conclusion
is is uh is point out that the um the
opponents of us in this motion
um are dealt with us in this subject
with some detail
um uh Owen Matthews here has written
about this extensively an excellent book
which I strongly recommend you all to
buy
um it's about the Russian response to uh
to the Ukrainian war and written very
boldly in the middle of the war rather
than waiting for it to end but he says
in the book very clearly sanctions did
not work in deterring Russia from going
further after they invaded donbass and I
have I'm afraid to quote him saying of
sanctions now where he says the fact is
that Kremlin fears neither a backlash
from an elite nor from the people of
Russia over the economic decline imposed
by sanctions things would have to get
far far worse worse than ever in living
memory for an angry silent Russian
middle class to contemplate regime
change
indeed Owen does say it's an excellent
book I want you today I mean does say
that the uh the consequence of pujin
being toppled which is one of the
putative consequences of the sanctions
of him being probably the worst regime
in Moscow than having peace in there it
is not wise policy at the moment to hope
for Putin to go the people who take over
on them are far worse
we have a problem now how do we end the
sanctions
curious fact of sanctions so easily
imposed that they are the most difficult
to end I think there's about a hundred
sanctions regimes operating around the
world now mostly out of Washington
okay uh and the the answer to that is um
that they don't end easily they end with
great difficulty and often not at all we
can have a big problem in ending these
sanctions I want you to know they hurt
but they don't work thank you very much
Simon Jenkins our first speaker thank
you very much I'm now going to invite
Anna Reed to speak Anna as a historian
and journalist she was cave
correspondent for The Economist and the
Daily Telegraph in the early 90s and is
the author of Borderland a journey
through the history of Ukraine the
fourth edition of which has just been
published and as other books are the
Shaman's coat a colonial history of
Siberia and Leningrad tragedy of a city
under siege
1941-44 which was shortlisted for the
duff Cooper prize it's been translated
into 17 languages and is just going into
Romanian so still spreading from 2002 to
six Anna directed the think tank policy
exchanges Foreign Affairs program she is
a trustee of the Ukrainian Institute
here in London Anna you're 10 minutes
thank you
so
are sanctions working or not they are
working
right now they're helping Ukraine to
defend itself and hopefully to win the
war
longer term they will restrict the
growth of the Russian economy which will
in turn restrict Putin's ability to wage
more Wars making us all safer
whether we like it or not while he
remains in power we are back at Cold War
style containment
the sanctions should stay in place we
need to make sure they're enforced
because as Simon Says historically
they're evaded
and ideally we need to make them
stronger
Richard's The Economist here so I won't
go into detail on the sanctions
themselves or their economic effects but
in brief
uh uh the West response to the invasion
in February was remarkably unexpectedly
strong and Swift and unified that was
near Universal condemnation in the U.N
weapons started to be shipped
immediately and the first package of
sanctions was agreed and I think we're
now on to our sixth seventh package I've
lost count
they they were on a completely different
scale
from the smear slap on the wrist
in terms of sanctions that the West gave
Russia in 2014 after it initially
invaded the donbathand Crimea
they cover hundreds of state-connected
individuals and entities who've had
their assets abroad Frozen doing
business with them is banned and they've
been slapped with travel bans that list
is still expanding
on the financial side all but essential
Financial transactions with a very small
number of Russian banks are banned
Russian banks are out of the Swift
International payment system credit
cards issued by Russian Banks don't work
abroad in addition the portion of
Russia's Foreign Exchange Reserve held
in central banks abroad has been frozen
and that makes up about half of the
total Russian Reserve
on trade export to Russia of a wide
range of goods
um sensitive ones and high technology
products in particular is banned it
includes micro microchips vitally on the
import side Europe is dramatically
cutting its purchases of gas and oil on
the gas there was originally a rather
vague plan
um never laid out in detail to cut down
on purchases but Russia jumped the gun
by itself first turning off the Taps
using the need for maintenance of the of
the Nordstrom pipeline as an excuse and
then it actually sabotaged
extraordinarily the two Nordstrom
pipelines itself
so you're you're prevented from buying
more Russian gas willy-nilly
on oil the sanctions have not yet come
into Force they'll do that next month
from December the 5th uh Imports of
Russian Seaborn Imports of Russian crude
will come to an end and that will be
extended in February to all oil products
the G7 is putting together a price cap
on Russian oil the details of that have
not yet been announced but that will
come into a force also next month last
of all over a thousand Western firms
under pressure from customers in part
have voluntarily withdrawn from Russia
either closing or selling up completely
or mothballing operations
more firms have halted investment plans
so however this this message massive
package of sanctions have affected the
Russian economy so far
when they were first announced there was
when the war broke out there was Panic
shelves emptied ATMs more or less
stopped working the ruble crashed
since then things have stabilized but
only superficially shelves are full
again but with substitute more expensive
Goods inflation's running at nearly 13
rubles were covered but thanks to
exchange controls and the fact that
Imports have collapsed
on the all-important question of energy
prices they're coming down again the gas
price is coming down again after its
spike in the summer thanks to some
rather Nimble
um finding of alternative sources of
Supply by Europe and oil is down to 87 a
barrel So Below the magic 100 a barrel
which is in normal times the the level
at which Russia can balance its budget
that's partly due to another phase of
another covert break outbreak in China
but also due to this imminent G7 price
cap
the Russian economy as a whole is
forecast to shrink by over three percent
this year over two percent next those
are disappointingly small figures but
they mask much bigger drops in sectors
dependent on Imports so high-tech
manufacturing telecoms Aviation
High-Speed Rail and vitally defense
so how is all this helping Ukraine win
the war
the the the extremely important direct
and immediate way the sanctions are
helping Ukraine is by preventing Russia
from rearming
so in these first nine months of its
suicidal unprovoked War it suffered
enormous losses of military kit perhaps
two to three thousand tanks five to six
thousand on on apcs hundreds of
artillery pieces and aircraft
it still has lots of dumb unguided
Soviet era shells left but it's running
out of smart modern missiles
Ukraine's defense Ministry reports that
captured Russian weapons have used
cannibalized spare parts from other
weapon systems and sometimes even
Electronics borrowed from you know
consumer white goods
another indicator of sanctions how
sanctions are hobbling Russians arms
manufacturing is that Russia's having to
buy weapons from Pariah States drones
from Iran guided shells according to us
intelligence from North Korea
longer term most economists agree that
Russia is set for stagnation you know
sort of skimming through various reports
you know the words that crop up are sort
of dismal chronically sick
impoverishment
and that that is set to continue
irrespective of sanctions even if he's
left if even if we lifted sanctions
tomorrow the West would still be
diversifying away from Russian
commodities
you know the permanent loss of gas sales
to Europe will seriously hit government
government revenues China will not make
up the shortfall even if it were willing
to the infrastructure doesn't exist the
necessary pipelines don't exist
Russia's lost access to International
Capital markets foreign investors have
been put off for perhaps a generation
and it's losing its own best and
brightest Minds as educated young people
flee because they don't want to be part
of Putin world and they don't want to be
conscripted
another point that there was Tim Ash
long long term time Russia and Ukraine
Watcher with bear stones
um puts is that while Putin stays in
power unless he moderates his militarism
which he shows no sign of doing Russia
is stuck in an arms race with the West
and has happened for the late period
Soviet Union that will bankrupt it
you know something Western policy makers
ought to say to themselves three times
every morning in the mirror is Russia's
economy is only slightly larger than
Spain's
you know for all its imposing vastness
on the map and it's ridiculously
overblown sense of its own importance
Russia is not a great power
you know U.S defense spending alone this
year will be over 700 billion dollars
that's nearly half of Russia's entire
annual GDP
if all the NATO countries step up and
fulfill their promise to up defense
spending to two percent of their gdps
Russia will be outgunned even further
you know all this will not necessarily
mean a moderation of Putin's aggression
nor will it necessarily mean he's
shuffled aside by the elite or that
there's any sort of popular mass
movement against him Owen's going to
talk about the effect of the war on
Russian Society
but it contains Putin it reduces his
danger to us
it reduces his room for maneuver and I
think you know that may be for the
foreseeable future the best that we can
hope for but it's still certainly worth
the price
in conclusion to get back to our motion
our sanctions against Russia working yes
they're helping Ukraine to win by
hampering Russian arms production yes
they're making Europe more secure by
forcing us to end our dependency on
Russian energy
yes they'll weaken Russia economically
long term which while the current regime
stays in place makes us all safer
let me pose a counterfactual to sum up
Russia Russia Simon's argument is that
sanctions should be discontinued and
Military Support for Ukraine continued
um in other words energy purchases
should resume at the same time that
we're sending arms to Ukraine first of
all that would incred that would
embolden the Kremlin that would send a
signal to the Kremlin that plays that
that we're losing interest that we're
going to give up on Ukraine it plays
also straight into their narrative that
the West is hypocritical decadent week
it would encourage the Kremlin to carry
on with the war
second it's not tenable at home you it's
it's simply too incoherent a policy to
to to keep it up it's unsustainable
politically domestically
third lifting sanctions would harm
relations with Ukraine it would
completely undermine Ukrainian morale
and it would undermine a country which
is a vital buffer state for us I'll come
back to it more when we have our extra
minute at the end
you know this is we're helping fellow
Europeans this isn't a this isn't a this
isn't a it isn't a repeat of Iraq or
Afghanistan we're not you know we're not
invading Ukraine we're not setting off
another civil war we're defending fellow
Europeans
um helping them defend themselves that
they can carry on with a way of life and
rights that we take for granted
um you know they don't want to be part
of Putin's crazy stalinist fascist sort
of Orthodox mystical mashup dream world
you know the big the big picture is very
simple and so is the answer to this
motion thank you
Anna Reed thank you very much uh Anna
arguing against our motion sanctions
against Russia won't work and our third
speaker tonight will argue in favor of
the motion that sanctions against Russia
won't work Richard Connolly is as Anna
was saying a specialist on the Russian
economy an associate fellow at the Royal
United Services Institute ruse here in
London and the center for a new American
Security in Washington DC Richard is
director of the consultancy Eastern
Advisory Group and his most recent books
are Russia's response to sanctions and
the very short introduction to the
Russian economy so we're giving you a
very short amount of time 10 minutes
here uh Richard to speak in favor of
this motion thank you very much Philippa
um I should say the book on Russia's
response to sanctions was published in
2018 I'm not as quick as Owen here I
can't write a book in six months so uh
that was referring to the sanctions
imposed in 2014. okay so I'll start off
by saying that I I think I also need to
put my cards on the table as Simon did
earlier and say that because I think
this is very important that I think that
a robust response to Russia's
aggression in Ukraine is needed and I
think many components of that have been
in place but what I'm going to argue is
that I'm skeptical as to whether
sanctions are the way to do that most
effectively so I'm going to make three
points so the first one is to do with
impact there has been an impact on the
Russian economy the Russian economy is
smaller today than it would have been
had it not invaded Ukraine on average
the Russian the average Russian citizen
is also poorer than they would have been
at Russia North invaded Ukraine and
Russia's longer term prospects are Bleak
they're Bleaker than they were before
the war and they're already Bleak as
Anna pointed out in her remarks prior to
the war somebody spends his time looking
at Russia's various different economic
forecasts the Russian Russia's economy
has grown at an average rate over the
last decade less than one percent a year
isn't an economy that was doing very
well anyway and there are reasons we
could go into that as to why
Russia suffered from an overbearing
state
I argue in my books that a lot of that
was down to the 2014 sanctions that the
Russian government in its response to
Western sanctions used that as a pretext
to increase its control over the Russian
economy and over the Russian over
Russian Society more generally so the
state blooms large in the Russian
economy and that breeds all sorts of
negative things for economic performance
including low private investment
entrepreneurs in Russia are scared to
invest because if they can become
successful uh inevitably they have their
assets stolen from them in a process
known as register or raiding
and there's low levels of competition in
the Russian economy because the Russian
State lose large and because private
entrepreneurs have their assets gobbled
up
and Russia's working age population has
been shrinking since 2010 that's its
labor force number of people available
to work so as an economist I look at
those factors and you say things weren't
um things really weren't looking very
good
prior to February and all of these
things contributed to what was a
extremely thorotic race of pre-war
growth and things have got worse Imports
Asana pointed out a down sharply
especially from the West although they
have actually risen from some other
places inflation Rose early on peaked
around about 17 early in the spring
um and some of around half of Russia's
State uh foreign exchange reserves were
frozen those held in Western
um central banks
but this is my main point here at the
first one we should be wary of
exaggerating the impact of sanctions and
remember impact is an Effectiveness
impact's just
um what the observable impact is on
economic indicators Effectiveness is
about does it get do sanctions change
the foreign policy of the target country
in this case Russia because Russia's
exports of Natural Resources have
largely continued uninterrupted
and because what measures have brought
in been put in place
um to uh to restrict those exports have
actually ended up serving to push prices
up
the Russian States ended up having more
more than enough money to pay for the
war and to ensure this is key that it
supporters are allocated funds
right the people who support the regime
moreover Russia is in the Russian State
and the society is adapting that's what
countries do when they're placed under
sanctions Simon listed all of those
different countries that have
experienced sanctions in the last a few
a few decades all countries adapt they
don't sit there and wait for sanctions
to weaken their societies and their
regimes instead they adjust they're
removing Target
and in many ways this process of
adaptation is easier in authoritarian
societies faced with a choice between
looking after everybody The Wider
citizenry as might be demanded in a
democracy or simply looking after those
that matter to a regime's ability to
survive an authoritarian system
inevitably opts for the latter and
that's what's happening in Russia today
it's what happened in Russia after 2014.
the well-meaning of very often
well-heeled muscovites and other City
dwellers in Russia who never supported
Putin anyway I simply ignored by the
regime and even though the economy is
getting smaller the pie is getting
smaller the funds that are available are
given to those that support the regime
people in the elite but also other
people elsewhere across the country
resources which become increasingly
scarce as the economy gets smaller a
channel to those who are vital to regime
survival the military the Security
Services Workers in state-owned
Enterprises monograd the the one city
towns the backbone of the putiness
system
so let's look at some of the it effects
the impact since February inflation Rose
as Anna pointed out but has been in
Decline since the summer compared to
Western economies where it's on its way
up half of the foreign exchange reserves
were frozen but they have since been at
least partially replenished more than
half of the value of those frozen have
been added by the Russia Central Bank
since February
sanctions were imposed on Russia's oil
industry price as well all sorts of
restrictions on the purchase and uh and
transports and dealing in Russian uh in
Russian oil were imposed in this pushed
prices up as the we Ruble weakened
Sharpie in the first months of the war
this had the cancer intuitive effects
and actually mean that Russia's Ruble
income Rose at least until the summer
this meant that we're more rubles for
the Russian state to spend on the war
and supporting uh an allocating funds to
its supporters and that's important
because the Kremlin pays its bills in
Rubles not in dollars
whilst Aruba has appreciated since the
summer the dollar value of Russia's
hydrocarbon exports remains well above
average levels and I'm skeptical as to
whether any
um price cap would work the Russians
have said then we just won't sell you
the oil if it's not at a price that is
set by the World Market if that happens
prices will go up even further
unemployment's barely gone up even if
the official figures are likely to
overstate the number of people in work
and parallel Imports that's the
unlicensed Imports of goods from third
countries have filled the stores of many
shops albeit prices are higher but
nevertheless a lot of Russians are still
getting the things that they're used to
getting
trade with the West has plummeted trade
with China and the likes of turkey has
boomed
um which brings me to my second Point
countries adapt and in doing so they
change the fabric fabric of the society
that existed before the sanctions the
very process of adaptation in an
authoritarian Society involves
centralization and the strengthening of
pillars of regime support this happened
after 2014. it's happening now it means
the increasing censorship and use of
official media to shift the blame for
hardship onto the regime's externally
and potent opponents it means greater
State control over the economy cronies
and managers estate owned Enterprises
are strengthened as they're given
responsibility for supplying Goods that
can no longer be imported from
traditional sources these Goods because
they're in short supply rise in price
cronies take charge of supplying them
they all line their pockets all of which
adds up to a system that closes ranks
becomes richer and more unified even if
this comes at the expense of the welfare
of wider Society but in an authoritarian
Society the welfare of society isn't as
important as it is in a democracy of
course it's desirable if the cost isn't
too high for the ordinary citizen to be
well off but if push comes to shove as
it is now in Russia then the Kremlin
will opt to provide simply for those
that support it
now what I'm saying now isn't just a
hypothesis of how I think things will
develop in Russia in the near future it
is that but it's also precisely what
happened after 2014 in the position of
sanctions then this is what I argued in
my book The the economy and politics
became more centralized the regime
became even more repressive and the
prospects for social change were much
reduced sanctions gave the regime
pretext to do all of that
this moves me to my final Point by
imposing sanctions that seem to be based
on the principle that the the more we
impose the better we risk eroding the
political will of our own societies to
continue supporting Ukraine providing a
military sport Etc and resisting Russian
expansionism some of the sanctions
especially those that are designed to
reduce Russian export revenues such as
the
price cap have the added effect of
raising prices in our own countries now
in some ways this is admirable only by
showing that we're prepared to pay a
heavy price can we hope to ensure that
the Russians also pay a correspondingly
high cost but to date we've paid an
extremely heavy price we see that in the
form of rising inflation and all sorts
of other forms of economic hardship that
we're seeing across Europe now all the
while the Russians and in particular the
Russian State continue to make money the
more we distort the global energy and
Regional energy markets the more prices
will rise and that's bad for us good for
Moscow
the real problem we have is that the
longer the wall carries on and the more
the energy markets are distorted by
sanctions the greater the risk that
support for Ukraine in Western societies
and elsewhere will waver
this to me seems counterproductive
so to sum up although I'm in favor of
sanctions that hamper Russia's ability
to produce weaponry and to tap
International Capital markets we really
need to be more realistic about the
effectiveness of sanctions and their
unintended consequences sanctions make
Target societies poorer but that isn't
enough if the target regime adapts as
the Kremlin did in 2014 and continues to
do today the impact of sanctions is
diluted and the process of adaptation
only strengthens rather than weakens the
target regime all of which takes place
while Western societies pay a growing
price for sanctions that could be the
very thing that causes its Collective
will to support Ukraine to waver
under that scenario there would only be
one winner and that I argue would be
Russia thank you
foreign
thank you very much and our final
speaker I can see questions coming in
already but but hold those thoughts that
you have we want to hear from our final
speaker making the case against the
motion that sanctions against Russia
won't work oh in Matthew's Russian
expert author of five books as a war
correspondent Owen covered conflicts in
Bosnia Lebanon Afghanistan chechnya Iraq
Ukraine for 10 years he was Moscow
bureau chief for Newsweek uh Owen's new
book already flatteringly referenced by
Simon is overreach the inside story of
Putin and Russia's war against Ukraine
it's been described by The Daily Mail as
Robert Harris storytelling territory and
by the telegraph as a remarkable
achievement with Matthew's expert I like
an All-Seeing drone buzzing from one
side of the conflict to the other I
don't know what you think of that but
Owen you now have 10 minutes to make
your case
thank you very much
um let's start by interrogating the
motion what gives us the right to ask
that question will sanctions work will
they not work
the facts that underlies that question
is the premise is that we have a choice
I would argue that we don't have a
choice that frankly we have to impose
sanctions because that is right and
proper and we cannot look the East End
of Europe in the eye if we were not to
do that it is a moral issue as well as a
practical issue or I would say a moral
issue first and foremost Beyond a
practical issue however I this tonight
we're discussing the practicalities of
it and I would start to explore that by
posing the counterfactual by turning the
whole
reality of the last nine months on their
head and imagine a world where we were
still doing business with Russia
that world would be a world which would
confirm all of Vladimir Putin's worst
assumptions about the way the West works
back in 2014 in February Angela Merkel
and all the leaders of Europe and the
world
lined up to express their outrage about
the annexation of Crimea this will not
stand at Angela Merkel this aggression
on the European continent cannot be
allowed everyone lined up to express
their extreme condemnation
packages of sanctions were put together
they were sanctions primarily first of
all actually targeted personally at
various Kremlin connected individuals
not really at the roots of the Russian
economy
but the sanctions were imposed as the
West's statement what happens 14 months
after the annexation of Crimea Angela
Merkel signs a deal with gasprom
for a 10 billion nordstream 2 pipeline
against by the way the strong objections
of The Americans
that shows the Russians that the West
the West's words are written in water
Angela Merkel whatever she says whatever
principle she may claim to appear adhere
to will be always secondary in the minds
of the crown and back then to the West's
addiction to cheap gas
and as we know from reporting from
political reporters far better connected
than myself uh Alexander for instance
the editor-in-chief of echo muscular
radio stations the one thing that
surprised the Kremlin most of all at the
beginning of the outbreak of this war
2022 invasion was their shock at how not
only the West responded but also how
private companies responded they were
horrified and mystified why because they
not unreasonably because like all human
beings the Kremlin believed that Putin
believed he was deeply deluded about
many things and deeply misinformed about
many things but one thing where he was
actually quite reasonable in his
assumptions was he believed like all
human beings that the future would be
like the past and what it what had
Russia's been experienced being in the
past it had been of an absolutely
cynical West whose sanctions were
ultimately toothless because they did
not include oil and gas by the way the
later sanctions of package of sanctions
also do not include gas because the
Russians actually effectively sanctioned
themselves on that by blowing up their
own pipeline in the north stream too but
the point is the the takeaway was
I would say in this imaginary world
where we were still doing business with
Russia they would all their assumptions
about the West cynicism would it be
justified and furthermore the War I
think was actually predicated on that
lack of action
so one could actually argue I think much
more effectively that the problem one of
the reasons or on one of the ways in
which the West I think could have acted
to prevent this war to contain Russia to
send a much stronger message would
actually was actually to have imposed
far harsher sanctions in 2014 and
actually that's the problem is not that
sanctions will not work is that the weak
sanctions of 2014 did not work true
which is completely right about that and
Simon as well they did not work they
encouraged the Kremlin to believe that
they could push further and get away
with it again except to the Kremlin
surprises We Know This Time It's
Different
just a few words about the actual
Effectiveness about of sanctions is that
actually
um Richard is obviously far better
informed and in detail about than I am
but the point is about sanctions is that
they work in poisoning the Russia's
Russian economy in the root
specifically for instance for the first
time in decades The Benchmark Brent
crude and Euros crude which is always
traded at the same levels have over the
course of the summer since the beginning
of the war uh been trading at about a 30
dollar per barrel discount in other
words Russia in other words the uh
Russia's big mates China and India are
buying Russia's oil at a massive
discount and Russian oil to produce
according to a Saudi aramco study a few
years ago is around between 42 and 45
dollars a barrel if you had 42 and 45
let's say you get to roughly the cost
price plus the discount is a gets to
about 75 dollars a barrel
that discount is a sanctions discount by
the way China did exactly the same to uh
to to Iran they also buy Iranian oil at
a massive discount so the money that
actually goes from that 85 a barrel when
you take into account extraction costs
and the discount at which they're
getting the the Russians are forced to
sell it means that they actually only
keep 10 to 15 per barrel
and that is a very serious problem
China
is supposedly we all think Russia's big
diplomatic Ally in the world and that
they are at the beginning of the war
they actually came out and basically
blamed NATO and and and and the the
United States for pushing Russia into
this war but the reality is that major
Russian Corporation major Chinese
corporations are pulling out of Russia
and they have I mean including synochem
there's a giant
hydrocarbons and concerns Banks ICBC
Bank the new development Bank the Asian
infrastructure Investment Bank and Union
pay which is China's answer as you know
to Visa Mastercard they've all pulled
the plug on Russia Chinese companies are
effectively observing
American sanctions why are they doing
that because of Russia does 70 billion
dollars now rising to about a hundred
thanks to extra Imports of crude oil but
now let's say 100 billion dollars of
business with Russia
but China does 2.5 trillion dollars
worth of business with the US and the EU
they know very clearly which side their
bread is buttered Russia is China's 11th
largest trading partner they don't care
really about their about losing that
business for political runs they
actually
the sanctions have actually
prevented and very strongly damaged the
Russian economy by removing that
economic that source of
finance of a capital and also the
technological exchange because the major
Chinese technology companies that could
have stepped in and provided the
microchips which they're pulling out of
washing machines to fuel their their um
to power their
cruise missiles and their tanks that
could all have come from China but the
Chinese technology companies are wary of
U.S sanctions so actually even countries
which do not officially subscribe to U.S
sanctions have de facto actually being
brought under that gravitational field
and have damaged Russia's capabilities
not just of economic development but
also for of uh of of of of Waging War
now finally I mean going back to the
forensics of who is not affected within
Russia by sanctions now Simon is you
know is absolutely right he has a long
and very enviable and admirable track
record of speaking out against foolish
badly thought out Western interventions
particularly over the Iraq War but
and he is furthermore right that in fact
the upper echelons of the Kremlin
are personally unaffected they don't
care about the fortunes of the oligarchs
they don't really care about the future
of Russia's engagement with the West
they have subscribed to what one might
describe as a sort of the
ultra-nationalist fantasy
Back to the Future world that is the
world of the people who are in charge
there are rather few of those people
they are specifically the old KGB men
who surround Putin those are The Men Who
Run Russia and they are the men by the
way who fantasize about who have
achieved what very few old men actually
uh many what many old men may fantasize
about but very few achieve and that is
actually creating a future that
resembles their own past but there's
actually a much larger silent majority
in Russia
for whom Putin is demonstrably clearly
very bad for business
and that silent majority may not be in
charge
their pain threshold is enormously High
we must not confuse uh the Russian
voters with Western voters it's not
about the economy stupid they'll put up
with a normal enormous amount before
they come up come out on the streets but
nonetheless you actually have created
thanks to sanctions a gigantic silent
majority within Russia which actually
has a strong vested interest in seeing
some kind of regime change some kind of
what some kind of Reform or some kind of
move movement onwards from the current
sort of death cult which currently rules
them so my final conclusion concluding
point is we the sanctions work in ways
that we don't necessarily understand but
the point is that they are also
inevitable and morally
morally
and a profound moral obligation that we
cannot ignore any thank you
foreign
thank you very much
um so uh I want to start actually with a
question that popped up very quickly uh
online uh when we're looking at a
particular sanction a particular uh
pushback which is affecting Russian
citizens and the questioner said I
believe that blocks on the emigration of
Russian citizens now are
counterproductive in that the loss of
the young trained Metropolitan Elite
will weaken the Putin regime do the
panel agree and Anna actually I'd like
to come to you first on your thinking on
that the blocks on the emigration of the
young Russians who have wanted to leave
in their thousands
foreign